Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Cecilia Bernabeni
E tutti ricorderemo.
Per sempre: sarà scritta
nella nostra storia, dell'Italia.
Accendiamo il televisore,
e vediamo il decreto
che sancisce la chiusura
dei confini del nostro Paese.
Delle nostre regioni.
Delle nostre città.
E per la prima volta,
ci chiude in tanti in pochi metri.
Ma vi rendete conto?
Nessuno l'avrebbe mai pensato.
Si dice
che il battito d'ali di una farfalla,
dall'altra parte del mondo,
abbia veramente un grandissimo
impatto su dove siamo noi.
E così è accaduto:
dalla Cina, che sembrava così lontana,
un paese così distante.
Eppure, da lì è arrivata in Europa.
E ancora, nelle Americhe.
Non ha risparmiato proprio nessuno,
questo virus invisibile.
Guardate.
Lo avreste mai detto che avremmo visto
una città tanto deserta?
Che saremmo stati chiusi
mesi e mesi nelle nostre case?
Incredibile.
Se dovessimo guardare,
attraverso questo scorcio che vedete,
e osservassimo queste città,
guardassimo nel passato,
e vedessimo la nostra storia:
non solo la nostra storia italiana,
ma anche la storia degli altri paesi.
Vedete, è vero: abbiamo vissuto
delle crisi devastanti.
Prendiamo, ad esempio,
l'attacco alle Torri Gemelle,
l'11 settembre 2001.
Siamo usciti da quella data, quell'evento,
con una paura, un terrore -
le nostre relazioni
sicuramente si sono modificate.
Ma mai come adesso.
Perché vedete, in quell'occasione,
nonostante la paura del terrorismo,
nonostante, davvero,
il terrore degli attentati -
e ancora, vediamo un altro esempio:
nel 2008, Lehman Brothers.
Il fallimento di una delle più grandi
banche d'investimento del mondo.
Sembravano assolute certezze.
Eppure, a oggi,
se facciamo un paragone con quelle crisi,
se i nostri figli leggessero un domani
delle crisi che abbiamo vissuto,
e che vi menzionavo,
e guardassimo a quello
che è successo oggi,
sarebbe riduttivo fare
un termine di paragone.
Perché prima, seppur con dolore,
seppur con paura,
ritornavamo alle nostre vite,
ritornavamo alla nostra socialità.
Ritornavamo a vedere gli altri.
Ad oggi, è molto diverso.
Niente ha avuto più impatto
sulle nostre relazioni
di ciò che abbiamo vissuto
in questo momento.
Ed è emerso l'emozione,
il fattore più invalidante
dell'essere umano:
la paura.
Ma vedete, come ogni onda,
come ogni grande rivoluzione,
abbiamo due opzioni:
cavalcarla,
e quindi controllare questa rivoluzione,
questo cambiamento, questa crisi,
consapevolmente seguirla;
oppure lasciarci trascinare,
e vederla come una grande minaccia,
invece che come un'opportunità.
E così forse sarà per molti di noi.
Ma spero davvero
che riusciremo, seppure con dolore,
a cogliere quest'opportunità.
E a trarne qualcosa.
Vedete, prendiamo un esempio:
lo smart working,
il tanto discusso smart working.
Ad oggi non è più un'utopia: è una realtà.
Lo vediamo in tutte
le aziende adesso, ormai.
Ormai è obbligo, quasi.
E vedete: se guardiamo al passato,
tante multinazionali,
negli ultimi anni,
hanno provato a implementarlo
come metodo di lavoro.
Ma non ci sono riusciti:
Perché?
Mancava la fiducia, non ci si fidava;
e quindi non lo si utilizzava.
E adesso ci troviamo in un momento
in cui per forza dobbiamo fidarci,
non possiamo permetterci più
di non fidarci.
Deve nascere un altro spirito
di collaborazione fra le persone.
Era già necessario prima:
ora vi lascio, lo lascio a voi.
E quindi, ad oggi
è diventato davvero fondamentale
avere una cosa per fare business.
Vi rendete conto?
Oggi possiamo fare business anche da casa!
Serve una sola cosa: la credibilità.
Senza quella, signori,
non potremo muoverci.
Abbiamo un grande strumento,
che è la tecnologia.
Vi rendete conto?
Negli ultimi decenni, tutto sommato,
possiamo davvero
organizzare il nostro tempo,
utilizzare questo strumento,
per mantenere delle relazioni
con le persone.
Averle anche in un modo nuovo,
in un modo diverso.
Vedete, abbiamo una libertà diversa,
se vogliamo vedere
questa onda, questa crisi,
anche come un'opportunità.
Ad oggi, attraverso uno schermo
possiamo interagire con infiniti contatti.
Invisibili, ma potenziali per noi.
E quindi, quando andiamo,
attraverso i nostri social,
attraverso i nostri strumenti,
oltre alla credibilità e alla fiducia
cerchiamo di capire
chi influenza che cosa.
Perché ognuno di noi
influenza qualcosa o qualcuno,
Chi decine, chi centinaia,
chi migliaia di persone.
Circondiamoci di queste persone,
per espandere le nostre relazioni
e creare delle sinergie.
Oggi, se lo vogliamo,
il mondo è nelle nostre mani.
Grazie.
(Applausi)